finesse to it do you live your life as  you play chess do i grind in real life  as well  it's all about the long game  haven't you got a course coming out um  with with the word grind in it is that  right is this a dance course or uh it's  a no it's a chesapeal course simon  what's it called uh grind like a  grandmaster  are you going to be pulling some moves  in it like  you as we'll have to buy it  [Laughter]  may not be some slick moves in there oh  it's gonna be in line now to get that  adjustable course it's not out yet but  it's coming it's coming but it is a  question right and we should put that  question to everyone watching you know  do you play chess the way you live your  life you know are you carefree are you a  saver are you caught are you cautious  yeah are you a gambler i want to know  you can tweet us using the hashtag  chesschamps i agree i think that must be  the best name for a chess course so far  it's quite unique grind like a grand  master i like it